so after a few years Captain Jack is
back Pirates of the Caribbean on
Stranger Tides alright so it's been a
few years since the last Pirates of the
Caribbean movie and I admit I loved the
first one I just thought it was really
cool I expect you to be like cutthroat
island it was actually a badass movie
and it started a whole pirate craze
among pop culture not very many movies
actually influenced pop culture and the
next two came out yeah not a fan and now
we have the fourth installment in the
franchise and is it good there are a lot
of good things about it yeah so with
this one Jack Sparrow and a few other
people are out to find the Fountain of
Youth and after that basic crazy
convoluted Pirates of the Caribbean plot
now we have Penelope Cruz looking hot
for the record I don't think every chick
is hot just the hot ones and a couple of
new people you don't really care about
except ian mcshane ian mcshane plays
Blackbeard in this movie he's looking
for the Fountain of Youth also coolest
villain in Pirates of the Caribbean
since like original Barbosa this dude is
badass he is evil [ __ ] he has really
good dialogue he's menacing all the
things that make badass villain stops to
Ian McShane his black beard now in the
first pirates I really liked Captain
Jack Sparrow and the next two I thought
he was just really forced like I've said
in other videos it's almost like the
director was like just do your Johnny
Depp isms even if it's the same line
that you've used in other Pirates of the
Caribbean movies in this one his
dialogue was actually a lot better than
the last two movies not as cool as the
first one and yes he does use lines that
he's already used in the other Pirates
of the Caribbean movies also like it
seems somewhat familiar though in jus
before I was like do use that in the
first movie come on so the stuff starts
to annoy me and there are a couple of
action scenes where you're like that's
what the what's going on
this is [ __ ] it's like impossible I
know it's supposed to be a fun movie
it's not like a pirate can like control
his ship with his sword so that's
unbelievable too but that works for the
movie and this just looked like a sloppy
action scene however there were some
good action scenes too so it was almost
like the movie is directed by two
different people I'll say that it had a
lot of what made the first Pirates of
the Caribbean good and it had some of
what made the last two bad like for one
there's too many people going after this
Fountain of Youth you're trying to keep
an eye on him you're like why are these
people going after it why do I care why
are these people going after it why do I
care there are easily two different
parties that could have been cut out of
the movie entirely and in the whole
climax you know it all comes to a head
and everyone's fighting everyone and you
realize you don't really care who wins
cuz everybody's a villain again the
first one you had good guys and you had
bad guys this one you have a
couple anti-heroes a lot of bad guys so
when they're all fighting your legs kill
each other off what do I give a [ __ ]
long as Jack Sparrow lives he's the one
we're supposed to root for he is it all
the rest of you guys you dressed
differently you're from different areas
you're the same crock pot of bad guys so
Pirates of the Caribbean had some clever
dialogue and that was cool to see it had
some cheap dialogue and that was stupid
and it felt like he got back to the old
school that made Pirates of the
Caribbean cool in the first place and it
had some stuff that made the next two
movies bad but all in all this is the
best Pirates of the Caribbean movie
since the first one but it's not as good
as the first one I would say it's a good
time no alcohol required I'm not gonna
buy it on blu-ray or anything like that
but I saw it and I enjoyed myself it's a
good summer movie and that's important
so did you see Pirates of the Caribbean
on Stranger Tides what's your favorite
pirates movie comment below let me know
and be sure to check out my new blog on
Jeremy Jones dot-com yeah I finally
launched that [ __ ] I got a blog up right
now I got more blogs coming I'll explain
more in another video but for now go
check it out subscribe follow do
whatever you do for blogs if you want to
hear more of what I have to say about
[ __ ] and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more